[Música]
el litio se está convirtiendo en uno de
los minerales más cotizados de todo el
planeta Hablamos de una materia prima
absolutamente indispensable para llevar
a cabo los ambiciosos planes de
transición energética y precisamente por
eso ya estamos viendo inversiones
multimillonarias Ya se está construyendo
la primera gran refinería de litio de
Europa es suficiente Reino Unido acogerá
Europa por parte de Greene su capacidad
productiva anual será de 50.000
toneladas de este material lo que
servirá para cubrir el 6% de la demanda
de coches eléctricos en Europa para el
año 2030 las baterías de litio son el
nuevo petróleo ahora bien Dónde se
encuentran exactamente las grandes
fuentes de litio para abastecer la
enorme demanda que está surgiendo Qué
implicaciones puede tener esta especie
de nuevo oro blanco para los países
productores puede ser el conocido como
Triángulo del litio una gran oportunidad
para que se produzca un nuevo Renacer
económico en América del Sur queridos
amigos amigas En este vídeo vamos a
responder a todas estas preguntas
arranquemos pero antes solo un segundo
la demanda de litio se está disparando
Sí pero también lo está haciendo la
demanda de cobre el tercer metal más
extraído de todo el planeta de hecho se
espera que la demanda de este mineral se
doble en poco más de 10 años solo hay un
problema hoy por hoy no se está
invirtiendo ni de lejos lo necesario
para poder abastecer toda esta inmensa
demanda Y claro como os podéis imaginar
poner en marcha una gran explotación
minera de cobre lleva mucho tiempo la
situación es tal que muchos expertos
están alertando de que la crisis del
Cobre está a la vuelta de la esquina
pero queréis saber más sobre esta crisis
que parece inminente que puede suponer
la escasez de cobre Cómo se puede evitar
puede ser una buena idea invertir en
este mineral Pues bien tenéis todos los
detalles en uno de los últimos vídeos de
si lo hubiera sabido el canal de
información financiera de motoactivos
con el que participamos os dejamos el
enlace abajo en la descripción dicho
esto arranquemos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
Aunque escuchemos hablar del por todas
partes hace poco más de una década no
era ni de lejos tan importante Por
supuesto eso cambió cuando comenzaron a
producirse los coches híbridos y
eléctricos esta era la previsión en 2008
el consejo nacional de investigación
concluyó que el litio aunque no era
crítico en el momento de la evaluación
de 2008 podría llegar a serlo en función
del nivel de crecimiento de nuevos usos
como las baterías de vehículos híbridos
y hoy ya es una realidad el uso del
litio para fabricar baterías se ha
multiplicado por 15 durante la última
década una creciente demanda que por
supuesto también ha hecho explotar la
producción de las más o menos 130.000
toneladas que se producen de litio cada
año cerca de las tres cuartas partes más
de 96.000 se destinan a la fabricación
de baterías evidentemente con semejante
demanda como os podéis imaginar se ha
disparado la inversión para encontrar
nuevos yacimientos y poner en marcha
nuevas explotaciones ahora bien sabéis A
qué países les está tocando la lotería
del oro blanco
[Música]
pues estos que veis en pantalla son los
10 países con los mayores recursos de
litio identificados hasta ahora os llama
algo la atención Exacto hoy por hoy el
cono sur de América concentra más del
50% de todos los recursos identificados
en el mundo prácticamente podríamos
decir que el cono Sur es para el litio
lo que Oriente medio es para el petróleo
es lo que se conoce como el Triángulo
del litio y además si a eso le sumamos
que esta región particularmente chile
también es uno de los mayores
productores de cobre que como
comentábamos antes es el otro mineral
clave en el proceso de transición
energética ya os podéis hacer una idea
del enorme peso que de repente está
cobrando esta región de una forma u otra
cada vez que veis las siglas esg o
escucháis hablar de combatir el cambio
climático estáis hablando de un gran
negocio potencial para estos tres países
el cono Sur Argentina chile y Bolivia
son actores clave para que los gobiernos
y las empresas de todo el mundo puedan
cumplir con sus planes la pregunta
lógicamente es que están haciendo estos
países Para aprovechar la la carrera del
litio que puede suponer tener unos
recursos tan grandes de lo que y lo más
ha calificado como el nuevo petróleo
Hasta qué punto el oro blanco puede
ayudar a estos países Pues bien veámoslo
[Música]
un nuevo despertar
lo primero que tenemos que tener claro
es que aunque los mayores recursos
identificados de litio están en el cono
Sur solo chile se sitúa hoy por hoy
entre los mayores productores del mundo
Australia es el número uno en este país
se produce cerca de la mitad de todo el
litio mundial pero insistimos en América
del Sur que casi casi podríamos
considerar como el corazón mundial de
este mineral chile es quien ha tomado la
delantera produce ya casi el 30% de todo
el litio que se extrae a nivel mundial
chile tiene una edad mayores reservas
delito del mundo un mineral que al estar
en las baterías de almacenamiento de
energía de autos y buses eléctricos
resulta clave en la lucha contra una
crisis climática y una oportunidad de
crecimiento económico que difícilmente
se vuelve a repetir en el corto plazo
Bolivia y Argentina tienen grandes
planes pero estos están avanzando más
lentamente que en Chile un país donde se
están tomando esta cuestión como una
gran prioridad nacional tener más lejos
en abril de 2023 el presidente Boris
anunció su estrategia Nacional del litio
uno de sus puntos más importantes es la
nacionalización de este recurso de hecho
el presidente chileno anunció la
creación de la empresa Nacional del
litio y la otorgación de contratos de
exploración y explotación tanto aenami
la empresa Nacional de minería como a
codelco la empresa estatal del Cobre
además según sus planes el estado
promoverá la generación de productos de
litio de mayor valor añadido como
baterías también anunció la creación de
un instituto chileno del litio para
llevar a cabo tareas de investigación y
desarrollo sobre esta industria es decir
en Chile el mayor productor de América
del Sur El litio será una actividad
básicamente pública
el anuncio despertó la oposición de
muchos actores privados chilenos pero lo
cierto Es que no es una sorpresa si algo
caracteriza a Chile es la producción de
cobre y sabéis que lleva casi Un siglo
nacionalizado de hecho esto es algo
presente Incluso en la Constitución la
gran minería del Cobre y las empresas
consideradas como tal nacionalizadas en
virtud de lo prescrito en la disposición
decimoséptima transitoria de la
Constitución Política de 1925 continuará
rigiéndose por las normas
constitucionales vigentes a la fecha de
promulgación de esta Constitución el
estado chileno mantiene vínculos y
programas de cooperación con el sector
privado pero en última instancia la
actividad de exploración y explotación
del Cobre depende de las empresas
públicas y ahora eso es exactamente lo
que Boris quiere hacer con el litio el
estado participará en todo el ciclo
productivo de este mineral creando para
ello una empresa Nacional del litio este
proceso compatriotas permitirá acelerar
la exploración de los salares de esta
forma la participación de empresas
privadas en esta industria se hará
siempre acompañando a las empresas
públicas es un modelo que con el cobre
les ha funcionado y ahora con el litio
quieren repetir
[Música]
sea como sea chile tiene un plan de
acción bastante más claro que el de sus
vecinos y eso que si hablamos de
precursores y visionarios tenemos que
mencionar Sí o sí a Evo Morales que ya
en abril del año 2008 promulgó un
decreto que declaraba de prioridad
nacional la industrialización de uyuni
para el desarrollo productivo económico
social del departamento de Potosí en el
caso de Bolivia el gobierno no optó por
llevar a cabo una nacionalización
completa sino a trozos es decir el
proceso se hace por yacimientos el
problema es que eso no genera mucha
seguridad jurídica porque no sabes
cuándo van a cambiar las tornas Así que
la inversión privada no despegó para
arreglar todo esto en 2017 se creó la
empresa yacimientos de litio bolivianos
pero aún así la producción de litio
continúa sin despegar en el país por
supuesto las fuertes tensiones políticas
que existen en el país tampoco están
ayudando y como la cosa no va nada bien
pese a todas las expectativas creadas
Pues fijaos que Evo Morales pide
nacionalizar el litio para que América
Latina la potencia Luis Arce denuncia
que el litio de Bolivia está amenazado
por la derecha internacional con la
tecnología convencional mediante
piscinas de evaporación Bolivia solo Ha
logrado producir 600 toneladas al año de
carbonato de litio por lo que todavía no
ha entrado en el club de los grandes
jugadores en el mercado de esta materia
prima para intentar salir de esta
especie de hoyo y conseguir que la
producción repunte ahora los líderes
bolivianos se están echando en manos de
socios rusos y chinos Bolivia recibirá
1290 millones en inversiones de dos
empresas de Rusia y China para su
Industria Del litio vemos qué ocurre
[Música]
Mientras tanto en la Argentina que os
voy a contar todo dependerá del
resultado de las elecciones el litio en
el país gaucho no está nacionalizado de
hecho en buena medida ha quedado sujeto
a las regulaciones provinciales
provincias que en líneas generales
buscan atraer la inversión privada
quizás porque ven que puede ser la
fórmula más rápida para poner en marcha
las explotaciones Sin embargo a medida
que se han ido acercando las elecciones
la idea de la nacionalización ha vuelto
a ponerse sobre la mesa diputados
impulsan proyecto para nacionalizar el
litio la línea de Cristina kirchner y la
idea de una nueva ipf la iniciativa
declarada de interés público la
exploración explotación concesión
explotación industrialización y todos
los actos relativos al litio y sus
derivados se trata del artículo clave
del proyecto al plantear la
nacionalización de toda la cadena de
producción de este recurso Claro que
nacionalizado o no el mayor beneficiario
de la explotación sería por supuesto el
gobierno la casa siempre gana eso está
atado y bien atado si sumamos todo la
carga fiscal independientemente de si es
nacional provincial Argentina es uno de
los países más caros de la región En
comparación con chile Perú somos poco
competitivos a nivel de costo fiscal en
cualquier caso los proyectos avanzan con
el funcionamiento de los proyectos en
construcción sumado a las ampliaciones
previstas de los proyectos activos
Argentina podrá explicar su producción
hasta más de 200.000 toneladas en esta
década a los precios actuales eso podría
suponer unos ingresos de unos 6.000
millones de dólares anuales no es una
cantidad equiparable a los ingresos que
generan las petromonarquías pero a largo
plazo el litio puede jugar un papel
clave a la hora de impulsar la economía
de estos países pero sigamos
luego Aunque lógicamente no forma parte
del Triángulo del litio y sus recursos
identificados son mucho más reducidos
tenemos el caso de México cuya reservas
identificadas no obstante se sitúan
entre las 10 más grandes del mundo Pues
bien en el caso del país Azteca en abril
del 2022 el presidente Andrés Manuel
López Obrador dictó la reforma de la ley
de minería de México entre sus puntos
principales encontramos la
nacionalización de toda la cadena de
producción de esta materia prima de esta
forma tanto la exploración como la
explotación el beneficio y el
aprovechamiento del litio quedan
exclusivamente a cargo del estado y así
es como surgió litio para México litio
MX a partir de ahora excepto para
aquellas concesiones ya otorgadas el
estado mexicano asumirá en exclusiva
todas las operaciones relacionadas con
este mineral ahora bien realmente
podemos hablar de un nuevo despertar
con mucho ojo porque en el pasado estos
países ya han perdido muchas
oportunidades sus reservas de litio son
inmensas pero las reservas conocidas a
nivel mundial están creciendo con fuerza
y tanto chile como sobre todo Bolivia
Argentina y México se enfrentan a un
importante problema en el caso de la
minería no son países particularmente
atractivos Esto es algo que en el caso
de chile puede no ser un gran problema
el país tiene recursos experiencia y sus
empresas públicas funcionan
razonablemente bien sin embargo los
casos de Argentina Bolivia México son
completamente diferentes en cierto modo
un desastre Y eso podría hacerles perder
esta oportunidad por qué Pues porque ser
los primeros podría animar la llegada de
muchas inversiones vinculadas para
producir productos de mayor valor
añadido con el litio sin embargo en
lugar de intentar aprovechar esa
circunstancia Bolivia México y Argentina
siguen atascados Eso sí México sí que
tiene un importante ventaja su enorme
industria Automotriz de hecho es uno de
los 10 mayores fabricantes automóviles
de todo el mundo Y eso qué quiere decir
que podría tener mucha facilidad para
desarrollar una cadena de producción
completa vinculada al litio la
oportunidad es muy clara pero para
lograrlo el gobierno mexicano debería
hacer las cosas de una forma muy
diferente a como las hace con Pemex Y
eso no parece nada fácil en cualquier
caso que los países latinoamericanos se
pongan las pilas nunca Mejor dicho es
algo que no solo les importa a ellos
atentos
[Música]
seguridad ante todo
desde el punto de vista geopolítico el
litio tiene una importante ventaja la
inmensa mayor parte de la producción y
también de las reservas se encuentran en
países razonablemente tranquilos con
altos niveles de libertad al menos y los
comparamos con muchos de los productores
de otras materias primas como el
petróleo y ojo porque es algo que puede
garantizar la seguridad del suministro y
podéis creernos y os decimos que tras la
invasión rusa de Ucrania ahora Esto es
algo que en occidente se empieza a tomar
más en serio especialmente en el viejo
continente de hecho la comisión europea
ya ha puesto su ojo el conocido como El
Triángulo del litio y de hecho eso es lo
que explica noticias como estas la Unión
Europea firma un acuerdo con Argentina
para obtener litio y cobre a cambio de
promover la renovables la Unión Europea
firmó un acuerdo con chile para obtener
litio y cobre a cambio de impulsar su
industria la alianza contempla también
promover la industria y las cadenas de
valor de este sector la Unión Europea
está dispuesta a invertir 45.000
millones de euros en América Latina para
asegurarse un acceso fiable a recursos
tan importantes como el litio y el cobre
decir que el dinero y el negocio están
sobre la mesa Bolivia Argentina y México
tienen que poner la quinta para explotar
cuanto antes esta oportunidad chile al
menos ya lo está haciendo sea como sea
llegados hasta aquí ahora la pregunta es
para ti crees que México Bolivia
Argentina lograrán aprovechar la
oportunidad del litio pueden llegar los
países latinoamericanos a desarrollar
actividades de mayor valor añadido que
la simple minería Cuál crees que sería
la mejor solución para impulsar la
producción del litio déjanos tus
impresiones en los comentarios y
hablamos debate y ahora si este vídeo te
ha resultado interesante No olvides
darle al botón de like y suscribirte a
visualpolitik si es cuando lo has hecho
un saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]